У суддівських мантіях та зловісних масках.
Це не святкування Хелловіну,
а протестна акція проти нечесних суддів,
які хочуть потрапити до найвищої судової інстанції -
Верховного суду України. Серед організаторів -
29-річна Катерина Бутко, активістка "Автомайдану"
та проекту PROSUD.
Моя маска сьогодні символізує
одного з недоброчесних кандидатів
до Верховного суду, який зовсім скоро може стати
суддею Верховного Суду.
Утім, часником Катерина бореться
з недоброчесними суддями лише на флешмобах.
В інший час її зброя - закон
про електронні декларації, команда однодумців та
квадрокоптер, з яким і вирушає в черговий рейд.
Мета проекту PROSUD - зібрати в електронну базу
якомога більше інформації про кожного
з понад семи тисяч українських суддів.
Це не лише декларації доходів,
статистика щодо їхньої професійної діяльності,
але й відомості про майно, які часто не збігаються
з тим, що судді офіційно декларують.
Недавно знімали прокурора, який задекларував
будинок площею 173 метри в Козині.
Але коли ми приїхали туди, виявили
і подивилися в реєстрі, що будинок
понад 700 квадратів,
а задекларував він тільки жилу площу, тобто
він написав 173, а там 700 плюс (кв. м.).
Тому потрібно перевіряти, звичайно.
Бути непроханим гостем біля будинку суддів -
небезпечно. Одного разу  квадрокоптер пошкодили
шістьма пострілами.
Судді недаремно бояться активістів:
кожне розслідування команда PROSUD
не лише публікує на своєму сайті, але й надсилає
до правоохоронних та контролюючих органів,
аби ті звірили дані, вказані в деклараціях,
з реальними статками суддів. Зібраними даними
користуються й інші організації, зокрема
громадська рада з питань люстрації
при міністерстві юстиції.
Вони реально круті. Вони молоді, вони завзяті,
вони небайдужі, вони ініціативні і вони розуміють,
чого вони хочуть. Це зразок, це приклад для інших.
Хоча в команді PROSUD
є депутати, сама Катерина в політику не збирається.
Своє місце бачить у поглибленні співпраці
між громадськістю і політиками.
Вірить, що активісти здатні впливати на владу.
Надихають ось такі невеличкі перемоги.
Наприклад, щодо цього прокурора вже вдалося
відкрити дисциплінарне провадження.
І я сподіваюся, що ми таки дотиснемо і його
буде звільнено. Насправді таких перемог
не так багато, вони дуже повільно йдуть, але йдуть.
Але є й багато розчарувань.
Приміром, після "ходи нечисті"
25 корумпованих суддів часів Януковича
все одно потрапили до Верховного Суду.
А звільнені судді-хабарники часто повертаються
на посади через те, що нелюстрований
Вищий адміністративний суд задовольняє
їхні скарги. Цього б не було, переконана Катерина,
якби існував незалежний Антикорупційний суд,
створення якого нині блокується.
У нас є і адвокати, і юристи, які, по суті,
можуть іти суддями, до яких є довіра і які можуть
вершити правосуддя. Ось коли таких людей
в нашій судовій системі стане більше,
коли орган, який буде проводити всю цю реформу,
до нього буде довіра, тоді я, звичайно,
буду задоволена.
Катерина планує нові видовищні акції,
аби звертати увагу на корупцію в судах.
Її, активістку Євромайдану, мотивує до боротьби
обурення, що судді, які виносили
обвинувальні вироки побитим "Беркутом"
активістам "Автомайдану", й досі на посадах.
Занадто високу ціну за нову Україну
заплатили її однодумці на Майдані,
аби тепер зупинятися на півшляху.